I have a balcony outside of my bedroom I
live in the Hollywood Hills it looks up
into the greenery there and looks really
nice and I can play music and stuff it's
so cool and so anyway so like say I
started I started writing say around you
know 10 10 30 11 something like that and
then I write till about five six or
seven around that time around five or
six I'm I'm gonna stop for the day and
what I do is I I stop for the day and
then after a little bit of time of
unwinding I go into my pool and I keep
it all nice and warm there and
everything and so I just kind of hang
out in the pool and if I'm not done with
something I think okay
um what do I want to do what how how do
I want to go further with this now that
I've written the first pass on it what
do I think about it how can I make it
better is there another element I can
bring into it did I add too much yeah
and whatever I'm just uh looking at it
critically and maybe I come up with some
neat ideas and then I get out of the
pool and I make notes on those neat
ideas that I came up with meditating
about it it actually is meditating and
then that's my work tomorrow when I get
up